RELATED TO DONALD TRUMP'S
BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
ALSO WITH US IS CNN SENIOR LEGAL
ANALYST AND FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, ELIE HONIG.
MICHAEL, YOU KNOW ALAN
WEISSELBERG WELL.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT WHAT HE
DID TODAY PLEADING GUILTY?
>> WELL, HE HAD NO OTHER CHOICE
BUT TO PLEAD GUILTY AS KARA JUST
SAID.
HE WAS LOOKING AT 15 YEARS BASED
UPON CRIMES THAT I HAD PROVIDED
THEM DOCUMENTATION ON, THAT
PROVED WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN FOUND GUILTY.
>> SO, YOU WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
PROVIDING THEM EVIDENCE THAT
THEY USED AGAINST ALAN
WEISSELBERG.
>> YES, I PROVIDED IT TO THEM,
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK, I PROVIDED IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I TALKED ABOUT IT, INCLUDING AT
THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
>> IN THAT CASE, KNOWING WHAT
YOU KNOW, DO YOU THINK THAT FIVE
MONTHS IS TOO LITTLE TIME FOR
WHATEVER HIS CRIMES ARE?
>> 100%.
I MEAN, LOOK, IT'S NOT MY CALL.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE JUDGE'S CALL.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT, THE WAY
THEY ACT AND THE WAY THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS IN NEW YORK
ACT, THE JUDGE, THEY GET
INVOLVED IN THE DETERMINATION,
WHEREAS, IN MY CASE, IT WAS NOT,
SO I DON'T REALLY -- I DON'T
WANT TO COMMENT ABOUT -- DO I
THINK IT'S TOO SHORT?
HIS NUMBERS WERE HIGHER THAN
MINE.
I COOPERATED.
I PROVIDED OVER 500 HOURS OF
TESTIMONY TO NINE DIFFERENT
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES.
>> YES.
>> AND I GOT 36 MONTHS.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT THIS, MICHAEL?
HE'S NOT GOING TO IMPLICATE HIS
BOSS, DONALD TRUMP.
>> SO, I DISAGREE WITH THAT.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
THEY'RE GOING TO ASK HIM
QUESTIONS, AND THEY ALREADY KNOW
THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY WANT TO
ASK, AND THE QUESTIONS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO ASK, IF HE
ANSWERS THEM TRUTHFULLY, WHICH,
IF HE DOESN'T, HE'S REALLY A
FOOL, BECAUSE HE IS LOOKING AT
SPENDING THE REST OF HIS LIFE
BEHIND BARS, WILL ULTIMATELY
IMPLICATE OTHER PEOPLE, NOT JUST
DONALD, BUT OTHER PEOPLE AT THE
TRUMP ORG AND IN THEIR BUSINESS
CIRCLES AS WELL.
>> OKAY, ELIE, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THIS IS A BIZARRE,
COCKAMAMIE, IF I CAN USE THE
LEGAL TERM FOR IT, ARRANGEMENT
WITH ALAN WEISSELBERG.
THIS IS PARTIAL COOPERATION.
IF THERE'S A TRIAL, THEN ALAN
WEISSELBERG IS GOING TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE ORGANIZATION, BUT
HIS TESTIMONY WILL NOT BE USED
AGAINST ANY OF THE PEOPLE, AND
JUST SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND, A
CRIMINAL TRIAL OF AN
ORGANIZATION IS JUST PAPER.
THE ONLY PENALTIES CAN BE
FINANCIAL.
NOBODY GOES TO PRISON OFF THAT,
AND THE WAY I WAS ALWAYS RAISED
AS A PROSECUTOR, AND I THINK
IT'S GOOD PROSECUTORIAL
PRACTICE, IS, YOU DON'T GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPTION OF HALFWAY
COOPERATION.
WE ALWAYS USED TO SAY, MICHAEL,
I'M SURE THIS WAS SAID TO YOU AT
TIMES, YOU'RE EITHER FULLY IN,
OR WE'RE NOT INTERESTED.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH CREATING
THIS SORT OF PARTWAY COOPERATION
IS, WHAT'S THE NEXT GUY GOING TO
WANT?
THE NEXT GUY IS GOING TO COME
ALONG AND SAY, OH OKAY,
PROSECUTORS, I'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
AGAINST A, B, AND C BUT NOT D,
E, AND F.
>> ISN'T THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
DONALD TRUMP?
AREN'T THEY SYNONYMOUS?
>> THEY'RE ONE AND THE SAME.
IT'S HIS EPONYMOUS COMPANY.
HE OWNS 95% OF ALL THE SHARES.
THE OTHER 0.5% IS OWNED BY A
TRUST.
THERE WILL BE NO WAY FOR ALAN
WEISSELBERG TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
HONESTLY AND TRUTHFULLY WITHOUT
IMPLICATING DONALD, THE
CHILDREN, AND OTHERS.
>> SO, IT'S JUST A FACE-SAVING
MEASURE, IN OTHER WORDS, THIS
ARRANGEMENT, ELIE?
POSSIBLE?
>> I THINK BOTH WAYS.
I THINK THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GETS TO SAY, WELL, LOOK, WE
CONVICTED ALAN WEISSELBERG.
THERE'S SOME VALUE IN THAT.
HE WILL GO TO PRISON.
>> IS THIS A WIN FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY, THAT IT'S
FIVE MONTHS?
>> IT DEPENDS HOW HIGH YOU SET
THE GOALS.
CLEARLY, THEY GOAL, WHEN THEY
STARTED THIS, WAS TO INDICT
DONALD J. TRUMP.
IT SEEMS TO ME THEIR GOAL IN
STARTING INDICTING ALAN
WEISSELBERG WAS TO FLIP HIM WITH
THE FEAR OF, WE HAVE YOU ON THIS
FINANCIAL CRIMES.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT TOGETHER,
CLEARLY THAT WAS A PLAY, AND NOW
IT HAS NOT WORKED BECAUSE ALL
THAT ALAN WEISSELBERG'S
TESTIMONY -- MICHAEL'S RIGHT.
WHEN HE ACTUALLY TESTIFIES, I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN TELL THE
STORY OF WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
TRUMP ORG WITHOUT MENTIONING THE
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT THE DEAL HERE IS THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO USE HIM AGAINST ANY OF
HIS PEOPLE, SO I DON'T SEE IT AS
A WIN EITHER WAY.
>> MICHAEL -- MICHAEL, VERY
QUICKLY, THEY DIDN'T FLIP ALAN
WEISSELBERG.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
THAT INSPIRES SUCH LOYALTY?
THAT SOMEBODY'S WILLING TO GO TO
PRISON?
>> STUPIDITY IS THE ONLY WAY I
CAN DESCRIBE IT.
IT'S WHY I EVEN ENDED UP WORKING
FOR HIM.
IT WAS STUPIDITY, A LACK OF
BETTER JUDGMENT.
ALAN, AS ELIE JUST SAID, ALAN
WI